for a large proportion we spend about
seven billion dollars a year
and a quite a large proportion of our r
d investment goes to the UK close to
probably a third but it's a very
substantial investment we make every
year in the UK how quickly do you think
the benefits of this Center will start
to come through in the pipeline well the
benefit of being in Cambridge has
already is already evident it's obvious
to us is that
seven eight years ago we had a couple of
collaboration with
institutions in in coverage today we
have 200
so in collaboration with some of the
best academic institutions in the world
the laboratory of molecular biology the
the University Cancer Research Center
and many others and so already we see
the impact that it has on our own
research and development now obviously
during the last year AstraZeneca has
become a household name to people who
would never necessarily have previously
known about you and what you do how
difficult has your job been given the
criticism that you've had from some
politicians
well and you know our job is in the
industry is really to focus on the
science and uh and and the best science
to develop products and we always focus
on this and we will be criticized
because some of our projects uh fail and
you know we have been lucky enough in
the last few years our productivity has
been high and we have had more successes
than we have had failures but failures
happen and we get criticized typically
we get criticized by you know investors
or the media but it's part of our life
now until now you provided the covid
vaccine at Cost you've just said that
you're going to stop seeking a modest
profit from it that's because you want
to channel some of those profits into
the antibody covert treatment yeah I
mean we've always said that we would
Supply this vaccine at no profit for a
period of time and by the end of this
year we should be close to 2.5 billion
doses of vaccine at no profit and we
still have all us to deliver at no
profit next year and we are
transitioning progressively to a profit
position with new orders and so that
will have an impact next year what will
inform the decision making as to which
countries which territories you seek to
make a profit from
oh actually what we said is that we will
have a tier the pricing policy and that
will go from no profit pricing all the
way to profit pricing and even the
profit pricing will be uh generating a
modest profit but for people at for
countries sorry at the low end of
economic
resources we will make no profit and
then we will have different pricing
policy according to how rich the country
is but the fact that you are seeking to
make a modest profit in some countries
some territories does that mean you no
longer think they are in a pandemic
but you know we
we have to you have to remember that the
disorders we are taking today will be
delivered next year we still have a lot
of orders that no profit to deliver so
they will be delivered next year so you
got to think of the infection
i i as as if you were already next year
and so essentially most of the world at
that point will be in a different phase
and we will be more in a regional
epidemic or original pandemic than a
global pandemic but you know we will of
course adapt to every circumstance and
countries that have low purchasing power
will will be supplied at no profit or
very low price and others will be a bit
more when you look at the profits that
the likes of Pfizer and moderna have
made from their covid vaccines does it
make you feel that you missed a trick in
in not pricing similarly not at all
because our plan I mean we always knew
that some some vaccines would be sold at
a profit and we made the decision from
day one that we would partner with
Oxford and and deliver this vaccine
around the world at no profit so
everybody could access it as much as
possible and again we've delivered more
than 2 billion also 30 percent of Global
Supply so far so it really has worked
quite well actually to what extent has
vaccine rollouts distracted you from
other developmental work you didn't
actually I mean if you look at it our
company is doing very well in the last
quarter we had eight positive phase
three readouts across a variety of
treatments in liver cancer in biliary
tract cancer and prostate cancer in
breast cancer well with one of our new
products we had totally transformative
data for the care of so-called her2
positive breast cancer so our pipeline
has never been as strong as it is today
our company is doing very well we're
very much on track to achieve this
famous 40 billion dollar sales Milestone
and that we announced we would achieve
by 2023 and nobody believed in at the
time and we are probably going to
achieve it one year ahead of time now
obviously alexion added a fourth therapy
area to the three that you were already
involved in the success of the vaccine
rollout has convinced you that this
could be a fifth therapy area
he's trying to do too much at once
no I mean we have uh we have a great
strengths in oncology and uh
we we believe we can be one of the top
three companies in the world in oncology
and maybe even better than that by 2025
we continue to do very well in uh in
cardiovascular in BIO Pharmaceuticals
overall and now we have rare disease the
the vax what we call the vaccine and
immune therapy unit is really looking at
managing this portfolio of products to
treat to vaccitate to to to vaccinate or
treat people with viral diseases we want
to maximize the value of these assets
and manage them better now whether we
invest in the long run in this field
remains to be seen but there's a lot of
synergies across this portfolio of
products and that's why we brought
brought these products together under
one single leadership